we had bucky brooks on friday show
correct chris brockman correct and
on monday's show this week greg cosell
both of the nfl media group and both of
them when i asked them about a
quarterback that they saw on tape that
was ready to win now and was shooting up
the charts or somebody that hasn't been
mentioned a lot in the first round
selections who have the best chance to
make it in the in the pros faster than
not we're here in desmond ritter of
cincinnati
and his head coach is joining us here on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line uh the
winner of seven national coaching honors
as his team made the national
championship semifinal out of cincinnati
luke fickle how are you sir
i'm doing well rich thanks for having me
you bet thanks for coming on uh let's
first uh talk about what's going on
in your world um
i guess we received word that your
spring game is going to go indoors and
fans will unfortunately not be able to
attend due to weather concerns is that
what's going on this weekend for you
right now yeah yeah i think uh for us
it's a little more important to uh
get a really good evaluation not having
desmond ritter anymore yes um
on two quarterbacks to you know give him
some
some better opportunities to uh to play
the game so we're gonna we're gonna take
it inside and uh eliminate the fans a
little bit but we'll still uh we'll
still have a scrimmage and we'll still
go about doing our
our uh
our evaluations and still make our like
the families because it's a big deal for
the families to come in town of course
and of course the fans too i mean um
folks there in cincinnati
i mean what an incredible football
season and and you know seeing your team
do what it did and
one of my favorite parts of the bengals
run was seeing zach taylor bringing game
balls to bars around town you know and
handing it out to fans
i mean fan the fans deserve obviously to
see your team and and celebrate in it
because they're it's been incredible a
heck of a run no
no it has been and obviously it's a
football town in general from high
school football to college football pro
football here and uh you know so yeah
it's unfortunate that we have to uh take
that away but uh we're kind of on the
back end of things next year as we as we
get into camp we know we'll open up some
things and make sure they get a good
sneak preview of uh
what we will be and what they will see
the next year during the season let's
start uh with uh your quarterback from
the last several years what a terrific
run again desmond ritter had at
cincinnati with you for you coach luke
fickle and so many times when we talk
about uh prospects in the draft we refer
to
the prospect as a kid but this is a
full-blown adult right like he's a
full-blown adult desmond ritter luke
right you said the last several years
but just for sure the last four so he
actually started
for all four years red shirt as a as a
true freshman um and had we known who he
was and
he didn't get hurt in camp he probably
wouldn't have redshirted um but yeah he
started for for four straight years and
uh so yes he is mature beyond his years
he has taken some lumps
and
people wouldn't recognize the lumps he's
taking because he wins but there's a lot
of lumps that went into playing as a
freshman playing as a sophomore as you
grow through
not just learning the game
the college game but also really kind of
grooming a team so it wasn't that he
just had to learn how to play
quarterback he had to kind of bring a
whole culture along from his freshman
year on i guess also was referring to
the fact he's a dad
too like he's getting he's getting and
he's a and he would throw another thing
onto the plate of being being a father
as well
in some ways i tried to tell him that's
a i thought that was a really good thing
for him and a good step because
desmond ritter in general is one of
those perfectionists and he can't ever
let it go and
when he had um
when he became a father when he had his
little girl i said this could be the
greatest thing
from serenity you need a chance to be
able to step away and maybe when you go
home and grab her and spend some time
with her you can actually have a chance
to let your mind relax
there's nobody who can
force you to let things go quite like a
child you know i would know six times
over i had wow i understand that i've
got three at home myself um what do you
mean by it's tough that he has tough
times letting things go though what is
that what are you referring to what he's
doing he's a perfectionist and and you
know unlike kyle like me too and i go
home and my wife's like can you just be
here now
and my head is running about things that
happen in practice and that's him i mean
he he wants to be great he wants to it's
always on his mind and which is an
incredible you know
quality to have especially as a
quarterback but i also think that
there's a plain task sometimes you got
to let your mind rest
and a little bit of that serenity
is a good thing and and for a guy that's
his perfectionist and wants to wants to
be perfect at all everything he does i
think it was uh it was a good way to
kind of get him to
be able to relax what teams have been uh
what what what are teams asking you
about him the most what are they picking
your brains about him the most luke
fickle you know they don't they don't
like i hear this they don't like to ask
the head coach because they think the
head coach only tells you the good
things you know they think they gotta
dive and dig into somebody in the
program
around that you know they're gonna sneak
some information from so i don't get as
many
calls but the guys that know me
their biggest thing is
tell me what
like does he does he is he really like
the pro like the learner the teacher
does he understand the game
um
you know how really smart and knowing of
all and i'm like
might be one of the greatest things he
has i sit in a quarterback room usually
every day and he could run those
meetings and he could teach it
luke fickle here on the rich eisen show
um the highest drafted cincinnati
bearcat however uh might just be your
cornerback
sauce gardener um when was the first
time you met him
walk you through that
uh
he was a junior in high school we had
this little thing we called club that
was unique to to us and
you know um
it was like what the olympic sports have
so we'd have a little club team and we
could practice them and uh so we would
do some be able to do some recruiting
with those guys and he came down from
detroit uh was that our club workout one
day
and uh
from then on somebody we became
obviously when we really started
recruiting him but
i didn't think he could play for us at
least in his first two years i'm like ah
we'll take him because he's long right
but he won't play for us you know you
know i don't think for two years at
least
and
and
i was completely wrong
i think it was game four or five when
all of a sudden we finally got smart
enough to put him in only because our
guys were tired we're playing ucf
all their tempo and i think maybe the
first series he made a play then the
second time he was in he pick sixed it
and uh all of a sudden we're looking at
each other like yeah why don't we just
leave him in the game
i was about to ask you is that one of
those moments where you share a look
with your assistants and your your
fellow coaches and you're like okay all
right yeah exactly what it is i kind of
looked at coach freeman and and those
guys at that time were like
maybe he's gonna be just fine in there
even as a young kid
so yes we we thank goodness uh you know
we gave him an opportunity and and uh he
proved me wrong and uh early on well i'm
just to walk straight through the front
door with you coach luke fickle i'm a
i'm a jet fan from new york city born in
brooklyn raised in staten island um i
want them i want them fourth overall i
want them the right i want joe douglas
to write the card in sharpie right now
and part of the reason why is again i
met him for about a minute at the
combine that's about it and all you know
so i i the eye test it was just like he
had me at hello
and and i saw the sauce chain but i also
didn't see that he that he um
he just he struck me as somebody who is
very self-confident but not um you know
self-absorbed is really what i got
and um i'm seeing tyreek hill on the
dolphins now and stefan diggs signed
forever in buffalo devonte parker to new
england and i want somebody who won't
look at those assignments and say yeah i
don't know
i i i
am i wrong is he either is he gonna is
he gonna be again they say i'll take
those guys or what luke i think you
nailed it i mean in the sense that he is
incredibly self-confident
but not self-absorbed and i have tried
to tell so many people this like he's
the best high-end guy i've ever been
around and i don't mean that like is he
the best player i've ever been around
the best corner
i think so
but he's the most delightful to be
around on an everyday basis just because
he loves to play he's got a great
personality he's got a great sense of
humor
and he's competitive as hell and you
know when he walked in the door here he
had this self-confidence that you're
like dude you're not that good i mean
maybe in two years you'll be able to
play for us but come on now
but it wasn't phony and
that's why when he went out there his
first time playing for us was against
ucf and
ucf was i mean lighten it up and they
were going as fast as they possibly
could
and i'm
petrified thinking okay we're going to
stick this freshman in here for you know
for a series just to give our guys a
break and
holy cow we didn't take him out after
that and it was like
maybe that self-confidence uh goes a lot
further than i thought so he is very
self-confident not self-absorbed at all
and
just one of those guys with a
personality
he only took you a minute yep if you
just spent more time with him you don't
like him even more just because that's
him from the day he walked in the door
to the day he left here well i think he
only had a minute because they were
putting him in that tube at the nfl
network with the confetti
for him for his you know his hero shot
was we were going to break you know to
play that footage and he he was just a
natural and i saw that and i'm like
that's that's who you want because
walk me through if you don't mind a
couple more minutes here um about how he
solidifies the defense from the back end
how does he do that
well
for us we ended up being able to cheat a
bit because on the backside of things
that you know this past year nobody
really even
wanted to you know
you know try him and much so
in a lot of ways you know they would
stick somebody back there that they were
not going to draw to anyway so we were
able to do a lot of different things but
i think the standard that he set
you know we had a guy on the other side
obviously won the thorpe award yes kobe
bryant yes and the two of those guys
ability
to be different
but
the same in the way that they had the
same expectation
um
it just it made it i mean it made our
whole group it made the confidence of
everybody around you greater and i say
that about a quarterback right to me the
quarterback is the key not just because
he's the offensive guy running but he
the court if you have a great
quarterback your defense has a hell of a
lot more confidence and i think the same
way when we had a guy like most
particular you know ahmad i don't call
him by his nickname
for three years i've been like no i
don't know that guy i know ahmad and i
always joke with him i said once you get
drafted then i will call you by your
nickname but until then
and uh but they just they give everybody
around them so much confidence all right
and their coaches as well so
great to have yeah i mean i uh
one of our uh glue guys which you
referred to because i had a uh i was
giving out a small amount of scratch for
an nil deal with gorilla glue this year
to kids who don't really expect having
an nil deal we gave it to alec pierce um
i believe after your game against notre
dame and i liked him too um so pound the
table a little bit for him and anybody
else that's in the draft before i let
you go on your day oh 100 i think he had
140 yards or 747 yards he killed it um
yeah
so you know i was spot on with alec in
case you guys are wondering
when he came here after his freshman
season we moved him to linebacker you
know so i was spot on with that one as
well
and then after the coach they came back
to us and said hey i think i'd really
rather play wide and feel like okay
let's we'll move you back to wide out so
thank goodness we moved him back to
wideout um but i think that the unique
thing about him is being around kobe and
ahmad
it made him and it challenged him every
single day those guys
their second year they probably fought a
little bit you know because he was in
the boundary with the mod all the time
and then this past year it was like they
slapped hands every day before every rep
and it was just like this healthy
competition
that i think really
made each one of them that much better
and uh
i think he's still scratching the
surface
he is a he is a guy that can make some
big plays down the field but i think
he's such a highly intelligent guy that
he's going to do nothing but get better
and better um with the game and uh for
us sometimes we just used him you know
in our the way we needed to use him and
taking some shots down the field but i
think that uh there's a lot more things
he can do before i let you go how often
do you hear from kelsey travis kelsey
where how often does he group here just
saw him last week yeah actually
back for the uh
former player outing so
i try not to hound him but i tell you
what he's one of those guys if you ever
reach out he always hit you back and uh
he always says there's anything we need
and uh with this nil stuff now rolling
in i told myself never ask you for for
money i promise you but we may ask you
for a little bit of time and uh we might
need to use your name and your face and
that personality to to help your uh your
former your future brothers oh you
should bother him all you want man i
mean
come on he's i figure hey when he's done
playing then we'll hound him but until
then let's let's keep building up that
uh that uh
that resume that he's got and uh we'll
uh we'll get him back here at some point
in time well i think that you know when
he goes back to ohio it might be canton
to be very honest with you i love him
and and we would love there would be
nothing greater than to celebrate that
so we're uh that's why i don't want to
bother him i don't want to give him that
opportunity
man
he doesn't need any more distractions
well i appreciate the time uh have a
great scrimmage now uh for your for your
uh spring um game and uh let's stay in
touch congrats on everything going on
with your program and
uh tell you know when you see ahmad as
you would refer to him tell him um i'm
i'm personally want uh i i want the
sauce to be brought to new york city i
want i want all the sauce is what i want
i will do that i don't know are you from
michigan originally too i am not i went
to uh the university of michigan from
new york okay all right well then they
missed out on him so but anyways besides
that i didn't know maybe you guys were
tied there at the hip
i just love his game and i'm serious uh
coach i'm i was around him for 60
seconds
and
you know when you see him it's
you're like okay so you play defensive
back like for real and and then
i saw the chain and then i saw just the
way he acted to everyone around him and
i picked up on all that in like uh 60
seconds and i'm like that's it that's
the guy
that's it and i tell you he's not phony
so that's the beauty of it he that is
him
all the time so um no he he he's done a
phenomenal job he's gonna do an even
better job at the next level and uh all
those guys had phenomenal comp maybe not
as good as your combine i didn't see
what the actual time was this year
i haven't done it yet i'm doing it i'm
doing it in three weeks out here uh as a
matter of fact yep that's where i'm
doing it um i'll have to make sure that
i'm watching oh yes yes uh well i mean
it'll be on all the sports tickers you
can't avoid it i figured i figured
everything would kind of pause and make
sure they flash to the whatever the 10
seconds
you will you will wonder if i have any
eligibility left let's just put it that
way
just don't ask me to do it along with
you okay you got it
coach take care let's do this again
greatly appreciate it you got that's
luke fickle head coach of cincinnati
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here